I've really evolved into more of an
edible guy than a week I mean smoking it
you got to here's the thing
it's so different though like because
okay hey okay let me just ask question a
round of applause people who have taken
too much of an edible before okay yeah
because here's the deal right what they
don't tell you is that an edible when
you smoke it right before you go into it
you're like oh yeah when I smoke weed
I'm high for an hour or so when I come
down on five but they don't tell you is
that an edible high goes like this
[Music]
[Laughter]
so if after an hour of eating inedible
you think to yourself man I'm as high as
I want to be you are [ __ ] you know you
got a little extra time on that ride I
remember the first time I took an edible
three hours in I was like I'm ready to
get off the ride now and they should put
something on the package it says you
could always eat more you can never eat
less and most the time the edible [ __ ]
you up that first time because you eat
it an hour later you're like I'm not
high and then as soon as you eat it
again as soon as you swallow that second
piece you start to get high and you're
like oh no [ __ ] you up now I will tell
you this and let me tell you a little
story ahead of time because I am also a
huge fan of practical jokes and I pulled
such a great practical joke on my
brother with an edible it was so good
don't feel bad for him that [ __ ]
has done some [ __ ] let me give you a
little backstory so the very first time
that I took an edible I I remember
walking into my weed store and by the
way the weed stores in La liked to get
your medical card is so easy so I went
into the doctor I mean when I was first
going in and I had a whole story planned
I had migraines when I was 12 fell down
so I walk into the doctor's office and
there's a poster on the wall that says
if you suffer from any of these you can
have your wreck it was a [ __ ] cheat
sheet right tell me the story I go I'm
just gonna memorize the first one it's
alphabetical and my to memorize it first
one you ever do this when you memorize
something by the way where you're like
got it
what was that yes half a second you're
back like I don't [ __ ] remember what
that was oh so I memorize the first one
I'm like okay got it
guy calls me in and I sit down there he
goes mr. Wolfe what seems to be ailing
you we feel like you need medical
marijuana and I just blanked but I
remember it was the first one so I was
like
autism he you should have seen him he
was like
[Music]
he said do you mean anxiety I go that's
it anxiety super anxious that I'm gonna
get autism can you just give me the
[ __ ] car
it's also funny like well so I'm at my
weed store and the guy who I always buy
friendly guy who owns a place he goes
you never you're not an edible guy huh
no I haven't tried one and he was like
you want to try one I said sure sure
sure and he goes what do you like to eat
and I said well for sweets I I like
baked goods and stuff and he said well
we actually made some blueberry muffins
fresh today and I was like well [ __ ]
look at you okay oh you got yourself a
little bakery in the back buddy that's
nice so he brings me out a blueberry
muffin and he hands it to me he goes
here you go
now in my weed store they have a place
where they they want you to smoke
responsibly they want you to get high
into the second room and the room has a
pool table it's got a big-screen TV it's
good PlayStation it's good Xbox it's got
an Apple TV and what I used to do is
with it I'd get a joint and I'd smoke it
I'd be high for an hour I'd come down
and I'd drive home so I thought well
that's what's gonna happen after I eat
my edible
right so as I'm eating the muffin and it
was delicious you know the edibles are
good now and you ever eat something
that's so good there's one crumb left
and you're like well I am eating that I
put the last crumb in my mouth and right
when I put it in my mouth the dude who
gave it to me walks into us you didn't
eat that whole [ __ ] muffin
[Applause]
and he goes well you gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here I got one why he goes you're
about to freak out for real I can't have
that here you gotta go home and I go you
didn't tell me not to eat the whole
muffin he goes I didn't tell you to eat
the whole moment either did I and I go
what's about to happen he goes you are
in for an uncomfortable eight hours look
those of us who done done drugs well you
know your mindset going in is really
important right and fear is not your
[ __ ] friend ok so I'm already
spiraling the drain I'm not even high
yet I'm like what dude goes how far do
you live from here I got on like 20
minutes and he goes you might make it I
try to walk out of there on my way out
he goes who's at your house I go my kids
he goes I wouldn't [ __ ] talk to them
so I go home and go to sleep I wake up
high now I hate waking up high I hate
waking up high and I'll tell you why
because look when I go to sleep I'm
basically saying whatever is happening
right now I'm pretty much done with ya
if I wanted to stay high I [ __ ] stay
awake pretty much done and I'd like to
wake up with a clean slate please so
when I wake up high I'm like [ __ ] you so
I called the dude who gave me the
animals man I go hey man like you ought
to let somebody know when you give them
tomorrow weed it's tomorrow [ __ ]
late there should be a note on the
package it says I hope you don't have
[ __ ] to do tomorrow either because
you're gonna be [ __ ] up for a couple
days man so I laid in bed because then I
started thinking what a great
opportunity edibles would be for a
practical joke on my brother
now before I don't feel bad hey who's
got older brothers in here right so [ __ ]
them we know what they did we know you
you my older brothers in here you
deserve every last little bit of [ __ ]
you get your whole life you
[ __ ]
so I laid in bed all day trying to
decide you know which one of my brothers
I wanted to give a near-death experience
to right
now before you feel bad for him let me
tell you what he used to do to me
you know those couches that fold out
into beds so he would fold it out and
then he would put me in it and he would
fold it to buck back up at a very young
age I had to learn to breathe like this
like a [ __ ] survivor so I was like
I'm gonna get this dude I call him on
the phone I'm like hey man you want to
come over and get high and he was like
yeah I go great I'm gonna roll you a
joint you're not ready for the edibles
that I have now look
anybody who knows when you tell your
brother your older brother he can't do
something so when I told him you're not
ready for edibles I was basically
standing on the edge of the dock like
this
I just needed him to take the bait right
on he took it he was like what what do
you would hope to I mean what you eat
bro don't you worry about me I'm your
big brother you don't think I can handle
you I've been getting high since you
were in mom and I was like first of all
yeah don't say in mom to me I don't like
[Applause]
there's got to be a better analogy than
that
I said but if you want to get come on
over he was I'm coming over now I had
bought him something called a space cake
guys a space cake will [ __ ] you up right
so I cut it in half and I cut his half
and half right and he goes how much you
eat I go I mean the half but you should
probably start with a quarter
you think I can handle will you handle
bro I'm ready I might even eat the big
half oh my god
if you insist and right when he finished
his half I turned to him and I did to
him with the due to the weight stored it
to me I got hey man he goes what I go
you gonna get the [ __ ] out of here and
he was like what why I go well I think
you're gonna freak out and I think it'll
be really funny so and he goes wait a
second you think I'm gonna freak out so
you're gonna send me home that doesn't
make sense bro
because you if you really thought I was
gonna freak out you'd want to watch and
make fun of me I think you're sending me
home cuz you know you're gonna freak out
bro that's what's gonna happen huh
you're gonna freak out that's why you're
sending me home we'll see what happens
I'll call you in an hour and I said I
look forward to your phone call an hour
and a half later he sent me a text that
was just numbers right
I texted him back I go what is that he
goes my vital signs I'm freaking it out
he was texting me from a blood pressure
machine in CVS even though you'll get my
numbers dude I might die in CVS I might
die in CVS I said you're not gonna die
but you could die I said if you don't
want to die the most important thing is
to never ever
and then I hit Send I turned off my
phone and I went to sleep because [ __ ]
him he put me in a couch everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you